hey 42 here names like Hitler Stalin and
Mao Zedong are often thrown around the
Sun of the evilest men who have walked
the earth each one causing the deaths of
many millions but there's a man equally
as despicable as Adolf Hitler yet very
few people even know of his existence
king leopold ii is one of the least
reviled tyrants from history yet he was
directly responsible for the deaths of
an estimated 15 million people he caused
a hidden holocaust that is rarely
mentioned a devastating an entire
country murdering the vast majority of
its population so why is so little
spoken about King Leopold's a second
some say it's because he only murdered
Africans Leopold was the king of the
Belgians between 1865 and 1909 nothing
about his upbringing spelled genocide or
psychopath as young prince he was
perfectly well behaved an upstanding
member of the royal family but it all
went to pot when he gained ownership of
the Congo in 1885 but let's just rewind
a little how does a king in Belgium come
to own a large large country smack bang
in the middle of Africa throughout the
late 18-hundreds Africa was being
slammed by Europe multiple European
countries attempted to and successfully
colonized vast parts of the continent
the methodology behind all this was
basically oh look Africa isn't as
civilized or technologically advanced as
us
let's take their land and freedom then
for 70 practice our religion use our
technology and we'll take all the
profits from their minimal rich loved
surely that's a better life than there
used to know the British Empire came
first and claimed the South the
Northeast and bit of the northwest the
French took the North East and
Madagascar the rest was snatched up by
the Italians and Portuguese oh and
Germany got their homes on a few bits as
well this left one massive gaping hole
in the center of Africa the Congo was
the hardest to take because it was far
from the coast
was covered in treacherous jungle
Leopold set his eyes on it knowing it
was rich in natural resources such as
rubber which was highly valuable at the
time so how exactly did Leopold come to
own the kundan bearing in mind it is 76
times the size of Pelton and was home to
millions of people did he simply invade
and stick flags everywhere
no that's the British Way he basically
said to the world's most powerful
nations hey you guys aren't using this
bid can I have it and they said sure
maybe you give us a bit of money for it
however the Congo is different to other
African states or might be others such
as South Africa and a Spanish Sahara
which were colonies of European
governments the Congo Free State as it
was known at the time was deemed the
private property of one man his own
personal plaything
Leopold's forms the International
African society which was a supposedly
philanthropic scheme to help Africans by
introducing him to Christianity and
giving them clothes but this was just a
ruse to get the Belgian government to
give him money
to start off his supposed humanitarian
project in Africa what
Leopold actually did in the Congo was
far from humanitarian he forced the
Congolese people into hard labor so hard
that millions died from exhaustion
disease and starvation the unfortunate
natives were forced to dig up gold hunt
and kill elephants for their ivory and
chop down hundreds of miles of forest to
set up rubber plantations all across the
Congo gold ivory and rubber were free of
the most expensive commodities in the
world at that time and King Leopold's
sold all the resources he ruthlessly
mind through slave labor to European
countries in order to generate vast vast
sums of money for his own personal
enjoyment as if all that wasn't enough
Leopold also sold slaves of Congolese
into slavery so how did King Lear
organize such a large operation across
an enormous country of millions of
natives well he was very very smart and
basically used his wealth and power to
turn the Congolese people against
themselves he recruited a large army of
mercenaries which he named the force
publique made up of Congolese natives
and paid them to enforce his ruthless
regime against their own people
Leopold set up a hierarchy handpicking
the most loyal members of the 4th public
to become governors over a specific
region of the country
governor's will be given complete dick
toriel control over their realm and they
had quotas of ivory gold and rubber that
they had to enforce if workers didn't
meet their monthly quota with raw
materials they were mutilated the most
common way was to amputate their hands
and feet and if they fled town the force
publique would amputate the limbs of
their entire family
instead governor's were paid via
commission so it was in their interest
to force those under their control to
work even harder the result of this is
that millions of natives were literally
worked to death either down the mines or
in the fields if you don't already hate
this guy enough he also used a Congo as
a giant hunting ground for himself and
his wealthy friends where they freely
hunted animals such as lions and
elephants no one knows for sure what the
exact population of the Congo was before
it was colonized by King Leopold since
it was so remote and dangerous but it's
estimated it was over 20 million by the
end of King Leopold's reign of terror
the population had dropped to well under
10 million so what ended his tyranny
competition the United States Britain
and the Netherlands owned large rubber
producing colonies of their own and so
King Leopold's efforts were stifling
their profits on the global market the
free nations forced Leopold's system
his land and hand it back to the Belgian
government whom by the way still treated
to Congolese people horrific Lee for
many years afterwards it wasn't until
the country gained independence in 1971
that the Congo was free from the tyranny
of Belgium but the ripples of history
run deep throughout the land they still
have a long way to go to achieve
political stability today thanks for
watching